America is not a racist country
you know I'm not sure first of all overt
identity politics just the the exact
type of identity politics that they
attack all the time let's put the
hypocrisy aside for a second hypocrisy
knows no bounds at this point with these
people
I don't know that when you say
we elected the first minority woman
governor in 2011 that it's the strongest
evidence that the U.S at least wasn't a
racist country it seems like a little
bit late in the game to be able to make
that case by the time that the country
was hundreds of years old we finally
elected the first minority female
governor which proves there's no race
problem in the United States or gender
problem no woman president ever
first woman VP not until 2020. these are
not particularly compelling data points
to be perfectly honest with you